come on come on dude this [ __ ] is racist
oh that's just
hard as heck racist yeah that looks like
a little nazax's new video yeah the same
energy
yeah the satan energy
yeah speaking of bro bro i thought the
funniest thing about that whole thing is
like how all these
like christian people are getting
offended so he
on his twitter he posted he's like all
right fine we'll release these two and
it was like a white shoe with the
chick-fil-a logo on it yeah yeah like
john 3 16 on that
or some [ __ ] like that he's a troll man
he doesn't care dude
he doesn't give a [ __ ] the joiner lucas
takes
were killing me what did he say again
he's like oh
what bothers me is you know old town
road
is like like an anthem for
kids and he just dropped that whole
thing out of nowhere
and i just think it's kind of [ __ ]
to
say that he has a responsibility to
children kind of like yeah i mean
it was never intended to be a kids song
yeah i mean the premise of all
entertainment is like you know
entertainment companies now they're
they're trying to get in front of
teenagers they don't care like
he performed at a high school and
someone referenced that as like oh
is you know to the little naz x because
little nasa was like oh
you have to raise your kids i didn't
tell them to do that and then someone
shows his performance at that high
school it's like
i mean what's he gonna do he's a
upcoming artist he gets an offer
hey man the school wants to bring you
out [ __ ] it i guess
right like the school brought him that's
not [ __ ] it's not his job
he's school schooled it i'm cool with it
right
yeah i don't know man did britney spears
have a responsibility
singing like oops i did it again well
that's what i mean i was like
the video the video is like incredibly
sexual
but like so was the slave for you video
wasn't it
mm-hmm like this shit's been happening
for a long time
yeah dude
vengo boys music video dude boom boom
boom boom
i mean i didn't remember that oh i mean
you know was it good that's that's where
the [ __ ]
unconvincing gay guy came from or was it
boys was it that [ __ ] now i have to look
it up
yeah now i forget what the [ __ ] um i'm
pretty sure
no no it wasn't that it was um
fangirl yeah we can watch the music
video in the in the bonus but
apparently he's getting sued now from
nike is that yeah
nike is suing him because they did the
shoes without
but isn't it legal to like paint nikes
and sell them
yeah like they're they're um
aftermarket yeah whatever they're
unofficial
so i wonder why he's getting sued then i
mean they i think they just
don't like the negative um
connotation i guess drop of human blood
or whatever yeah they don't like that
yeah they don't like that baby blood
baby sacrifice blood is in there
all their strong christian um
you know christian pastors ordered nikes
in mass
like they're actually a bigger market
than like you know jordan shoes and
you know um athletes and stuff it's
really the conservative
you know christian part of america that
nike really speaks to
yeah you know so they could not be
associated with those
you know uh illuminati sacrifice
shoes yeah yeah absolutely not dude
isn't there like an instagram called
pastors with sneakers or
remember this did we talk about this
last time no oh it's basically like to
uh shed light on how much money like
pastors make
oh yeah or priests or whatever and so
it's like people it's like preachers and
yeezys or something like that it's some
instagram account where they just like
take pictures of
rich or like pastors flexing basically
yeah i mean try and find that luke i'm
interested to see if
it's gonna work forever it's just like
dude the other thing about the joiner
lucas takes which kind of cracked me up
is
um kids don't have access to the
internet unless it's through their
parents
so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you don't want like also the also the
great part about that is
joyner lucas acts like we live in a
world where
a 12 year old isn't on tick tock
learning all kinds of [ __ ]
you know like that's way worse yeah 12
year olds on
tick tock and watching tick tocks like
this is what it looks like when i give
head
this is what it looks like when i give
head
play this sound and shake your ass and
see what your boyfriend
it's like yeah yeah
i don't know man i just think it was a
super boomer take and it made me laugh
who a lot of boomer takes yeah a lot of
boomer takes
it why do we give a [ __ ]
what kids see on the internet
the internet is not for teenagers it's
not
we never had a responsibility to them
and we are not going to start now
with little nazaks and leather pants
well what are we talking about though
because
kids and teenagers are different and
kids
like that like old town road was a net
it was an anthem for like six-year-olds
yeah that's true i guess i'm conflating
the two um
yeah yeah but in that respect like
little nauseas didn't tell them to play
that at birthday parties and
volleyball games and stuff i think that
came as a result of like minecraft and
tick tock and
it's also like it was also like the most
listened song in the world
ever which means it has to appeal to
every single aged
age and demo ever so of course it's
going to be a kid's anthem because it's
also like a senior's anthem
yeah yeah you know unfortunately for
little nauseas
he leading with a country single
he got everybody everybody
including you know
the bible bangers and stuff because they
thought that song was a bible banger
they were like this
when he's saying lean and stuff i think
he means leaning on the lord
i think that's what he's going for and
yeah of course yeah amen to that
amen so unfortunately for little knives
um you know because
those people don't really use the
internet like they're just still on
facebook
yeah they found out through that video
that he's gay
yeah but hold on
well now what you're telling me
the singing cowboy man is gay yeah what
the hell is this
uh what the heck is this [ __ ] we ran his
music all
at our july 4th barbecue last summer i
don't appreciate finding out that he's
gay
through myself he's fornicating with
satan
he is for satan
that's the devil it's the devil in that
boy
that's that's one of the things that
like one of the takes that i don't
[ __ ] understand is when people are
like he's worshiping the devil
like look at how evil society has become
this kid is
literally having sex with satan it's
like it's not evil it doesn't like
i know satan represents evil but he's
not like saying he's an evil dude he's
not saying he's gonna [ __ ]
that he you know what i'm saying it's
just like a funny
uh like contrast there's just
there are infinitely worse um
or like there are infinitely equal or
more offensive pieces of art i feel
than lil nas dancing on satan
yeah yeah exactly like
like um obsessed but not gay
i'm joking i'm joking
i'm joking i just was trying to think of
like a mainstream tick tock song right
now
that was the one i came i don't think it
you know it's not actually not that bad
of a tune you know
yeah no not my favorite song but not the
worst
bro that um you know addison doing the
fortnite emote store dances
on jimmy fallon man
you